UNDERWAY FOR PEOPLE WHO MAY BE
TRAPPED IN THE RUBBLE.
ANITA.
>> ALL RIGHT, TITLE 42 IS SET TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE MONTH.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SENDING MIXED
MESSAGES WHEN IT COMES TO HIS
BORDER POLICY.
OFFICIALS TELL THE ASSOCIATED
PRESS THE PRESIDENT IS QUIETLY
SENDING MIGRANTS BACK OVER THE
BORDER, AFTER STRIKING AN
AGREEMENT WITH MEXICO TO TAKE UP
TO 120 CUBANS AND 20 NICARAGUANS
A DAY.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT IT IS
CHRISTOPHER OLIVERAS.
AREAS IN SAN DIEGO, EL PASO AND
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY.
SO 100 CUBANS AND 20 FROM
NICARAGUA A DAY.
WHY DO YOU THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS BEING SO
-
HUSH-HUSH ABOUT THIS?
>> MIXED MESS TAGS.
ONLY GOING TO EXPELL 100 CUBANS
AND 20 NICARAGUANS, AND THE
THOUSANDS COMING ACROSS DAILY,
LAST MONTH, SOME OF THE SOURCES
I'VE TALKED TO, BETWEEN 34 AND
35,000 CUBANS FOR A SINGLE MONTH
AND YOU ARE ONLY GOING TO DEPORT
100, AND DOING INCREASED RAPID
EXPULSIONS UNDER TITLE 42, BUT
THEY ARE NOT INTENDED TO KEEP
TITLE 42, THEY WANT TO LIFT
TITLE 42.
IT'S TOTAL HYPOCRISY, TRYING TO
DO THE RAPID EXPULSION, BUT THEY
WANT TO LIFT 42.
MIXED MESSAGES, THIS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN TAKING PLACE FROM DAY ONE
HAVING THE CONVERSATIONS WITH
MEXICAN OFFICIALS, AND ONE THING
WE HAVE BEEN DOING EVER SINCE WE
LAUNCHED OPERATION LONE STAR
INITIATIVE BY GOVERNOR ABBOTT,
AND TO DATE WHAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO BY SIGNING
THE HISTORIC AGREEMENTS WITH
MEXICO, OUR STATE LEADSHIP ARE
HAVING CONSISTENT CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE MEXICAN AUTHORITIES.
LAST WEEK AT EAGLE PASS WE
WORKED WITH THE MEXICAN
AUTHORITIES AND WERE ABLE TO
CONTAIN AND CONTROL AN AREA, AND
EVEN TODAY IN LAREDO, TEXAS, WE
ARE TRYING TO CONTROL THE AREAS
WITH INCREASED ACTIVITY.
>> THE NUMBERS ARE ASTONISHING.
1 MILLION ENCOUNTERS SINCE
JANUARY, HISTORIC HIGH.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN TITLE 42
EXPIRES?
D.H.S. SECRETARY WARNS THERE
COULD BE 18,000 MIGRANTS
CROSSING PER DAY.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING THERE?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN HEARING
AS WELL BY TALKING TO THE MEN
AND WOMEN ON THE FRONT LINES,
STATE PARTNERS, FEDERAL
PARTNERS, LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT,
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
ANTICIPATING WITH THE LIFTING OF
TITLE 42.
18,000 A DAY, NOT SUSTAINABLE TO
THE SMALLER COMMUNITIES THAT
ALREADY HAVE A STRAIN ON
RESOURCES, AND THAT'S WHY THE
STATE OF TEXAS WE HAVE TO BEAR
THE BURDEN, TAKE ON THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE ALL
THE STATE RESOURCES, STATE
FUNDING TO TRY AND SECURE THE
BORDER.
IT FALLS BACK TO WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO DO,
AND POLICIES EFFECTIVE PRIOR TO
2021.
IN MARCH WE SAW HISTORIC NUMBER
OF 221,000 ON THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER ENCOUNTERS.
FROM THE PEOPLE I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO, MONTH OF APRIL WILL
BE HISTORIC.
HIGHEST NUMBER OF ENCOUNTERS IN
APRIL.
EVEN THOUGH, GOES TO SHOW YOU
THAT EVEN WHAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO, IT'S NOT MAKING A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE BORDER
RIGHT NO